bonjour bienvenue dans cette faq la
première puisque ça fait deux ans que je
fais des vidéos et j'avais toujours pas
fait de faq donc il était temps pour une
fois ça sera moi il y aura pas de
personnages médiévale antique bizarre
qui apparaîtra ça sera juste moi quel
est ton nom à quel âge as tu es bien mon
nom et justine et j'ai 25 ans c'est bien
avec des questions comme ça on va aller
super vite parle-nous d'où tu viens et
dans quel coin vie tu es bien compact
mes réponses commencent par et bien en
fait il se trouve que je viens du nord
et que je vis dans le nord toujours
donc en fait j'ai pas trop bouger je
viens de près de lille j'ai fait mes
études à lille et maintenant j'habite
dans la campagne autour de l'île voilà
donc je suis nordique
quel était le sujet de ton mémoire
j'avais joué à la version du 2048 des
reines d'angleterre mais j'ai jamais
connu le titre de ton mémoire mon
mémoire c'était sur les astrologues de
cours au xvème siècle donc en m1 j'avais
travaillé sur les astrologues de cours
uniquement à la cour de bourgogne
donc c'est pour ça que j'aime les
bourguignons et c'était parce que mon
directeur de mémoire et est spécialiste
de la cour de bourgogne sinon j'avais
pas de préférence particulière et après
donc j'ai élargi en m2 aux astrologues
de toutes les cours de france mois
seulement de france parce que sinon
c'est un peu beaucoup et le but c'était
de trouver qui étaient ces astrologue
donc j'avais trouvé des éléments de
biographie de pas mal d'astrologues pour
voir d'où il venait
la plupart été diplômé en fait avait
fait des études
donc c'était intéressant de constater sa
deuxième but c'était de voir ce qu'ils
avaient fait au service des ducs et des
princes et des rois qui le servait et ce
qui servait à quelque chose est ce que
les rois croyez en ski le ski leur
prédisait c'était ça la question
mais ça c'est dur a déterminé parce
qu'on n'a pas de témoignages disant oui
je suis persuadé que mon astrologue a
raison mais au moins on a des traces de
certaines prédictions
donc c'était ça mon sujet de mémoire à
la base c'était parce que j'aime et
l'astronomie par l'astrologie ou soc j'y
crois pas quoi c'est tout donc ça
m'intéresse pas plus que ça mais
j'aimais l'astronomie mon directeur de
mémoire et mais les bourguignons
voilà on va faire une petite pause parce
que monter est un fusée maintenant donc
au elle est peut-être passé refusé que
ça c'est un rôle bosse ça doit refuser
longtemps
attendons parce que c'est l'heure du
goûter en fait j'ai fait cette faq
pendant l'heure du goûter
j'aimerais savoir quel est ton parcours
qu elles ont été ou quels sont tes
études
quels sont tes projets ambitions
carrière envisagée et si tu comptes nous
parler un peu plus de la renaissance qui
est ma période historique favorite
waouh beaucoup de questions donc mon
parcours c'est ça mon parcours j'ai
commencé après un bac es à vouloir être
journaliste donc j'ai fait une prépa à
la fac j'ai par une vraie pas où on
bosse pendant des heures dans ce ca
c'est très peu pour moi donc j'ai fait
une prépa à la fac e pour préparer
concours de sciences po mais je les ai
pas eus
donc il y avait une possibilité
d'enchaîner sur une deuxième année de
licence d'histoire directement c'est ce
que j'ai fait et j'ai aimé l'histoire
donc j'ai abandonné l'idée de deux
journalistes et j'ai fait un master
recherche puisque à la base mon idée
c'était plutôt les hautes études
continuent en doctorat enseigné à
l'université et je ne voyais pas tout de
suite travaillé toute manière j'étais
encore bien étudiante donc j'ai fait un
master recherche sur les ducs de
bourgogne et les astrologues et oussalah
après ça finalement j'ai décidé pas
faire de doctorat parce que ça me
semblait très précaire est compliqué de
bosser après ça de bosser pendant de
bosser après un bref j'ai laissé tomber
cette idée peut-être que je suis à 21
jours plus tard et du coup après mon
master recherche j'ai tenté le capes 2
fois et je les ai eus
donc maintenant je suis prof pour ce qui
est la renaissance bien c'est peut-être
peut-être que je parlerai de la
renaissance un jour j'ai pas de
préférence comme j'ai parlé de
l'antiquité alors que je suis pas une
spécialiste de la période j'ai parlé de
plusieurs périodes possibles
donc même si le moyen âge c'est qui peut
m'en fous je peux parler d'autre chose
j'ai ma liste où est ma liste ma liste
des projets je crois qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de connaissances dedans
malheureusement donc un jour peut-être
que je parlais de la renaissance oui je
ne sais pas quand voilà est ce que ton
boulot de professeurs d'histoire te
plaît toujours autant après deux ans
quels sont tes aspirations pour le futur
passé en lice est passé ton agrégation
pour pouvoir faire des cours magistraux
en amphi oui mon boulot me plaît j'aime
ce que je fais c'est pas ça n'a jamais
été une vocation
enseigner en collège lycée c'est pas ce
dont jamais été mon rêve je n'ai pas de
rêve toute manière je n'avais pas de
boulot waouh c'est je veux faire ça et
rien d'autre donc ça me plaît beaucoup
mais je vis pas pour ça je le fais parce
que c'est mon travail et parce que
j'aime bien ça quand même mais c'est pas
comme certains vraiment une passion
absolue
en tout cas c'est bien ça me plaît mes
aspirations pour le futur ça serait où
est passé en lice et j'aimerais bien
parce que même si le programme parle
beaucoup moins de moyen-âge ça me plaît
un peu plus j'ai l'impression comme j'ai
eu un aperçu des deux j'ai fait et lycée
l'an dernier et collages cette année et
je cette année j'ai passé le dnl donc
c'est enfin voilà certification dnl pour
enseigner en langue étrangère donc pour
enseigner l'histoire en anglais ce qui
est possible par exemple si on enseigne
à des classes euros et des classes
bilangues et je les ai eus donc à partir
de l'an prochain
je pourrais si je veux demander des
postes s'il y en a dans ces secteurs là
pour enseigner en anglais et du coup
c'est un délit c'est donc ça me
permettrait peut-être d'accéder à des
lycées plus facilement et ça me plairait
pas ce que j'aime parler anglais
après ça sinon j'aimerais passer la
grève aussi dès que j'aurai l'occasion
c'est compliqué de passer la nuit dans
l'histoire et dur donc j'aimerais
essayer de demander un congé de
formation pour ça ça fait que pendant un
an on prépare la greg on est quand même
payer pas complètement mais on est payé
un peu et c'est plus cool parce qu'on
peut vraiment juste se consacrer à sable
et peut-être qu'un jour je ferai une
thèse que me disait ça me plairait bien
j'ai un collègue qui fait ça qui a
bientôt fini mais tardivement il sait
bien faire une thèse tout en enseignant
dans un lycée c'est possible de garder
un pied dans la recherche du coup le
canton d'enseignants collèges ou lycées
on prépare ses courts souvent un peu pas
à larache mais on n'a pas beaucoup de
temps donc il faut enchaîner on n'a pas
le temps de lire 36 livres sur le sujet
je lis pas mal de livres pour mes vidéos
mais en dehors de ça ça me manque un
petit peu cet aspect recherche et rédigé
quelque chose de conséquent ce que je
faisais quand je faisais mon mémoire
donc pour ça que j'aimerais bien faire
une thèse peut-être un de ces jours là
ça doit être un fusée par contre
je passe on entend le bruit du clapotis
de l'eau faire un peu smr le thé est
prêt esca montbazon tu fera une
conférence ou un atelier
oui je ferai une conférence donc à 12h15
le dimanche je fais une conférence sur
le bon et le mauvais sorcier on parlera
pas que de sorciers en fait mais le jeu
de mots était bien donc on va parler de
plein de pratiques magiques sorcelle
loric divinatoires tout ce qui était
pratiqué au moyen âge au xvème siècle
surtout 14 15e siècle et pourquoi est ce
qu'il ya des trucs qui était toléré
voire même pratiquée par des personnes
haut placées
alors que d'autres tu pouvais te faire
cramer si tu le faisais c'est ça qu'on
va essayer de voir pour ça que j'ai dit
le bon et le mauvais sorcier et donc on
va expliquer pourquoi est ce qu'il ya
des trucs qui passaient et d'autres pas
quel a été ton déclic pour l'histoire et
ce qui t'a poussé à faire une chaîne de
vulgarisation j'ai un peu soif donc je
vais boire du thé mais bon mes shows
mais bon on m'a viré ça c'est pas très
bon en fait les gages mais pour
l'histoire m'a comme je disais c'est je
suis arrivée là par hasard parce que
j'avais pas de passion pour l'histoire
au collège au lycée mes profs ne m'avait
pas déclenché de déclic désolé mais en
licence ça m'a plu donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai continué dès la première année
de licence alors que je préparais
sciences po j'hésitais déjà a lâché
sciences po pour continuer en histoire
et c'est ce que j'ai fait faire une
chaîne de vulgarisation de choses
déjà je regardais beaucoup de vidéos
moi-même même pas tant que ça devenait
risation en fait parce que à l'époque où
j'ai décidé lancé la chaîne j'étais à
fond dans what the cut
donc c'est pas vraiment de la
vulgarisation à moins qu'on considère
que le gars risée des vidéos des buts
sur internet c'est la vulgarisation
repas mais j'aimais beaucoup ça et du
coup ça me donnait envie de me lancer
aussi pour faire des jeux et après c'est
j'avais pas mal d'amis de connaissances
à l'époque qui se lançait dans la vidéo
aussi donc il y avait eu life works
qu'elle composait de l'eau et declémy
donc maintenance de life works est louée
clé mais c'est plein is no donc il ya
deux chaînes je mettrai les liens il y
avait aussi vendeurs espèrent qui a
lancé les chroniques de vesper que je
connaissais un peu aussi et
une autre est bénigne a aussi qui est un
autre pote qui avait lancé une chaîne
elle parlait de cosplay et maintenant
elle fait des let's play aussi alors
voilà du coup j'avais plusieurs
connaissances plus ou moins proches qui
se pensait dans la vidéo donc ça m'a
donné envie de faire pareil j'ai
réfléchi à ce que je pourrais apporter
moi même et je me suis dit que
l'histoire forcément c'était bien parce
que de 1
je connaissais un peu d'histoire et de
deux il ya pas deux j'avais 1 2 quand
j'ai réfléchi à cet épisode n'y a plus
de deux ma bref je me connais en
histoire voilà et donc je me suis dit
que je ferais des vidéos sur l'histoire
surtout qu'à ce moment là je pensais
qu'il y avait aucun historien qui
parlait d'histoire sur youtube en fait
j'en avais je savais pas mais c'est pas
grave c'est bien par mon histoire
quelle est ta chaîne youtube préféré
qu'elle vidéo en particulier une vidéo
en particulier j'en sais rien du tout
par contre une chaîne youtube je sais
pas si c'est ma préférée mais j'aime
beaucoup ce que fait balade mental ça
parle de science mais cette filmé de
manière je trouve sa poétique c'est beau
c'est bien filmé bien cadré bien monté
la voix est belle tout est beau dans ces
vidéos
voilà j'aime beaucoup balade menteur et
sinon est ce que tu vas bien est ce que
ton travail sur youtube de satisfaits
oui je vais bien merci
et sur youtube j'aime beaucoup ce que je
fais ça me prend énormément de temps
donc forcément c'est devenu quelque
chose d'important dans ma vie j'ai passe
du temps parce que tout en chaque début
de mois
j'essaye de sortir une vidéo maintenant
j'en peux plus régulière donc ça veut
dire que pendant le mois d'avant faut
que j'aille à l'abbaye emprunté à vif
que je fiche chez livre j'aime ficher
des livres c'est plutôt rare ça me plaît
de ficher les livres et que j'écrivais
tous que cherche des images donc ça me
prend beaucoup de temps et ça rythme un
peu ma vie en fait même si ya pas que ça
évidemment et j'adore ça m'a permis de
rencontrer des gens les tas de gens bien
que ce soit par internet où on s'est
rencontré en vrai parfois aussi et
de garder aussi un pied dans un aspect
historique un peu plus j'ai pas un peu
plus approfondie que quand je fais mes
cours à mes élèves
parce que quand on fait courir ses
élèves on lit certaines choses des
articles ou faux les documents des
manuels mais on va pas chercher beaucoup
plus loin parce qu'on n'a pas le temps
c'est quelque chose qui vient au fur et
à mesure ça donc là au moins ça me
permet de creuser un petit peu plus mes
sujets aussi parce que ouais aux élèves
voient pas non plus aller trop dans les
détails
alors que là avec vous je vais un peu
plus dans les détails donc vous avez
plus de détails que mes élèves de 4e
pour ce qui est de la faq je voudrais
savoir comment tu de c'est ça oui c'est
ça comment tu te débrouilles pour les
costumes pour les costumes
en fait j'en fabrique plus parce que
j'ai plus le temps mais à une époque
pendant longtemps j'ai fait beaucoup de
cosplay donc reproduire des costumes de
personnages de films de jeux vidéo de
manga mais moi je faisais pas trop manga
surtout film est donc que j'ai fait
plein de costumes et je les réutilise
sans gêne dans mes vidéos donc aliénor
c'était le robin des bois robin des bois
de ridley scott ce très bon réalisateur
qui a fait des aliens merveilleux
surtout récemment et donc elle c'est
robin des bois c'est marianne mes autres
costumes c'est par exemple la pirate
bassett et pirates des caraïbes
évidemment il ya une guerrière pictes à
un moment ça venait du roi arthur 2
le choc lui qui il ya eu un fils mort
arthur que j'aime beaucoup avec keira
knightley est d'ailleurs n'a tenu de la
romaine vient de là aussi donc voilà je
réutilise tous mes costumes et parfois
quand j'ai pas de costumes appropriés
soient gens n'utilisent pas son chèque
et moyens du bord j'ai jamais créé de
costumes juste pour chroniques de profs
j'ai cru voir un nerf custom et du coup
question tu pratiques le gn le jeu drôme
si oui je reste abonné sinon moi je sais
pas j'ai fait 2 g n
est-ce que ça suffit pour que tu restes
abonné je ne sais pas mais j'en ai fait
deux et j'en garde un bon souvenir enfin
personnellement il ya des trucs que pas
cool c'est assez jeune mais ça on s'en
fout c'est ses bienfaits gêne c'est bien
donc j'aimerais bien en faire un de ces
jours du jeu de rôle j'en ai jamais fait
vraiment du vrai jeu de rôle à 15 mètres
de jeu est tout sauf si tu conclus loup
garou dans ce cas là où j'en ai fait lui
mais ça me plairait bien parce que
j'aime les jeux de société sinon aussi
du coup à ses abonnés
est ce que l'on commence à te
reconnaître dans la rue il ya un an à
peu près on m'a reconnu dans la rue mais
c'était un événement où la personne
savait que j'allais ce qu'il a dit sur
twitter
donc c'est pas non plus complètement le
hasard hélas ce week end à tanger sortir
la vidéo dans trois mois donc ça au clos
ça aura plus aucun intérêt mais
récemment je suis allé aux geeks d'elsa
dean et il ya deux personnes qui m'ont
reconnu sur place
donc ça arrive à peu près une fois par
an après legging baisse c'est en
contrebas d'un type de public on
rencontre à la boulangerie c'est un peu
plus orienté
donc ça peut paraître peu plus logique
que si on me rencontrent c'est là et par
la boulangerie où as tu appris à chanter
si bien chez moi
face à ce merveilleux outil qu'est
youtube et ses versions karaoké
enfin ces chansons où il ya les paroles
avec avait comme ça on peut chanter je
pratique beaucoup ça j'suis pas sûr de
chanter c'est quoi le terme
merveilleusement bien non c'est bien
mais ça me plaît beaucoup donc voilà je
chante à la fin de mes chances de mes
vidéos c'est très bien ça me plaît
comment trouves-tu les chansons
magnifiques
bon bah c'est des chansons que je
connais donc si je fais une vidéo genre
sur le mur d'hadrien j'ai cherché une
vidéo soit en rapport avec la romantique
mais j'en avais pas en tête soit en
rapport avec un mur d'enceinte et pink
floyd donc je cherche une chanson qui en
rapport avec le thème de ma vidéo et si
j'en trouve pas je chante une chanson
que j'aime tout simplement donc les deux
prochaines vidéos il y aura un gros
rapport entre la chanson et la vidéo
dans le texte dans le thème vous verrez
musique préférée série tv préférée c'est
précis tout sa musique préférée plein de
trucs rock'n roll que musique classique
reggae chanson française
je sais rien moi j'écoute beaucoup de
musique de films aussi groupe groupe
paye à queen série tv préférée c'est
pareil il y en a plein dr au même si
depuis que david est parti c'est triste
tu as tu pensé du film the witch
est-ce que c'est réaliste très bonne
question excellente en fait c'est une
porte qui me la poser qu'est ce qu'on en
parlait justement donc c'est un peu
orienté mais oui j'ai beaucoup aimé le
film the witch si vous ne l'avez pas vu
regardez le parce que les baux des
images sont belles les couleurs tout est
beau il est filmé en anciennes anglais
donc c'est magnifique
j'aime écouter ça et après sinon d'un
point de vue historique et génial aussi
parce que ils montrent pas comment
étaient des sorcières parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas de sorcières au moyen âge
c'était des croyances pardon de vous le
dire mais il montre bien ce qu'étaient
les croyances par rapport aux sorcières
donc comme j'avais fait une vidéo sur le
sabot peu de temps après on m'a parlé de
ce film donc je les regardais et ouais
on retrouve tous donc c'est réaliste
parce que s'ils avaient eu des sorcières
au moyen-âge c'est comme ça que ça se
serait passé
on retrouve plein de choses on voit dans
le sympa qui est magnifique qui est très
bien fait on voit une vieille sorcière
qui s'ennuie du sang d'un nouveau-né
donc ça aussi on le retrouve dans les
croyances on voit un gros bouc noir
forcément en gros symbolique
il ya plein de choses qu'on retrouve
comme ça dans ce film à d'autres encore
sûrement que j'oublie mes à plein de
choses on voit plein de figurines et tu
chantes de belles chansons quels sont
tes passions les figurines et les belles
chansons j'aime beaucoup le cinéma ça se
voit avec les figurines
je vais très souvent au cinéma au moins
une fois par semaine parce que j'aime ça
la musique pas seulement chanter il
faudra sûr mais je joue de la flûte
traversière aussi et de la guitare
j'en ai joué depuis mes 10 ans jusqu'à
au bac et j'ai arrêté donc j'ai repris
tout ça cette année et je regarde
d'avoir arrêté et je regrette pas
d'avoir repris parce que c'est vraiment
génial de jouer surtout quand on peut
jouer à plusieurs
j'aime voyager mais une question sur les
voyages après j'aime la nature et j'aime
manger c'est bien qu'elle soit pas dans
mon champ de vision en tout cas sinon
dans mes passions le puzzle
ouais plus que le reste un peu bateau
donc le parlant de mes passions bizarre
le puzzle sega nintendo
ah oui c'est vrai tu dois être plus
jeunes xbox ps2 nintendo je m'en fous
j'ai pas eu de console avant mais 18 ou
19 ans où j'ai acheté une xbox 360 plus
encore donc avant ça je jouais sur pc
quand j'avais 11 ans jouer à counter
strike c'était cool quand j'étais petit
j'avais une gameboy advance
mais je veux pas tant que ça enfin le
faire une fois je voulais lire et ma
mère m'a dit ouais mais joue un peu à la
game boy avant parce que sinon tu aura
plus assez de lieux c'était pas ma
passion donc je répondrais xbox mais en
fait je m'en fous pourquoi as tu choisi
d'apprendre cette merveilleuse langue
qui l'italien s'est tu parler d'autres
langues et si tu pouvais en apprendre
une d'un claquement de doigts laquelle
choisir est urgent et après l'italien
parce que j'ai pris l'italien en lv2 au
collège c'est tout
on avait le choix entre italiens
espagnols et allemands et au moment où
il a fallu choisir se tait italien qui
me plaît donc voilà du coup il faudrait
qu'un jour j'allais en italie pour
mettre à profit mes connaissances
étendues
si je pouvais apprendre des langues d'un
claquement de doigts jeu claquerait des
doigts pleins de foi et du coup je
parlerai plein de langues parce que
j'aimerais bien pouvoir parler plein de
langues mais en fait je sais pas claquer
des doigts du coup faudrait que
j'apprenne et c'est dur donc que
j'aimerais bien apprendre le japonais ya
des trucs que je parle sinon je
comprends un peu l'espagnol je sais
parler l'allemand menus de restaurants
qui est une priorité je trouve
j'aimerais bien prendre l'islande et
aussi pour m'expatrier là bas parce que
ça a l'air d'être un pays fort bien est
ce que comme macroscopique va tourner et
afin qu au final ne jamais l affaire
banon sauf ce final je ne monte jamais
ça et ce rush restera un rush plus vous
ne verrez jamais je devais offrir une
bière pour féliciter de tes talents de
chanteuse est ce que si je te rencontre
à montbazon un rom faudrait quand même
la faire alors il me semble pour garder
dans les règles mais je pense pas qu'on
a le droit de faire rentrer d'alcool
dans la forteresse donc attention à
montbazon il ya de la bière et il ya de
l'hypocras qui est bien déjà
après si jamais on se croise en dehors
de la forteresse et que vous avez du
rhum mais que joe papp en dur après moi
c'est bon le groupe préfère tenir une
montagne de livres sur un sujet où bien
préfères-tu être sur le terrain pour
apprendre de ce sujet c'est quoi ces
questions être sur le terrain c'est
mieux je dirais même si c'est bien lire
des livres parce que du coup tu as la
vie d'autres personnes
par contre étant historienne c'est dur
d'être sur le terrain
il faudrait une machine à voyager dans
le temps et je n'en ai pas
donc lire des livres c'est bien aussi
dans ce cas argument contre argument au
final les deux c'est bien
parle-nous de tes voyages et quoi c'est
c'est mes voyages ben j'aime voyager
comme j'ai dis donc j'ai beaucoup voyagé
ça fait pas très longtemps que je voyage
pour par moi même avant ça j'ai voyagé
avec mes parents j'ai eu la chance
qu'ils aiment beaucoup voyagé eux aussi
est allé dans des destinations diverses
et variées j'ai fait les causes deux
fois j'adore les cosses je voudrais
retourner déjà plein de fois d'ailleurs
je dois emmener plein de gens en écosse
a qu'un qui me demande bien où va en
écosse
donc j'aimerais avoir un budget limité
et aller en écosse tout le temps ben
j'ai fait plusieurs trucs je suis allé
en grèce en egypte en irlande
je suis allé aux états unis là en
octobre j'allais à new york c'était mon
premier voyage tout seul et c'était
génial
moi j'ai fait quelques pays européens et
après je suis allé en norvège mais
c'était pour un séminaire
donc j'ai pas beaucoup voyagé enfin j'ai
pas beaucoup visité sur place j'étais
deux semaines en norvège à stavanger
donc par contre je retourne en norvège
en octobre et c'est génial parce que
plus le pays est froid et nordiques plus
il m'attire c'est ça le truc c'est que
l'école j'aime beaucoup et que la
norvège matière que j'aimerais aller en
islande au site
et donc là je vais en norvège vers
trompe zoo donc c'est tout au nord et
c'est au dessus du cercle polaire et
rien que le fait que en lisant des
chaussures trombes d'eau je me suis
rendu compte que c'était au dessus du
cercle polaire
ça m'a fait plaisir pour dire à quel
point le normatif donc voilà je vais
aller en norvège ça va être bien
il fera froid y en avait des aurores
boréales et donc voilà je vais mettre
fin à cette faq à présent montée et
froid ce qui est bête
j'appelle croquer dans une madeleine ce
qui est encore plus bête j'en profite
pour faire de la pub pour ce mug et où
le nothing john snow donc you know
nothing parce que c'est une remise en
cause constante de nos connaissances et
de nos acquis ce qui est important dans
la vie
donc c'est bien de se rappeler ça en
buvant du thé du thé rooibos ce qui est
très bon d'ailleurs je les prix j'ai pu
m'en veulent mais j'ai pas bu donc bref
je vous dis à bientôt
si on se voit à montbazon n'hésitez pas
à venir me dire bonjour est ce que ça me
fera plaisir
sinon on se retrouvera sur les réseaux
sociaux et
vous avez d'autres questions auxquelles
je n'ai pas répondu là j'ai répondu à
presque tout ce qu'on m'avait posé il me
semble mais s'il ya d'autres questions
qui vous viennent à l'esprit n'hésitez
pas à me les poser aussi dans les
commentaires je vais vous laisser et
finir monter parce que c'est l'heure du
goûter